the select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol will be in order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material represented during today's
hearing
good afternoon
this is almost no idea more un-american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
no idea more un-american
i agree with that which is unusual
because former vice president mike pence
and i
don't agree on much
these are his words spoken a few months
ago about donald trump's attempt
to pressure the former vice president
pressure him into going along with an
unlawful and unconstitutional scheme
to overturn the 2020 election and give
donald trump a second term in office
that he did not win
today
the select committee is going to reveal
the details of that pressure campaign
but what does
the vice president of the united states
even have to do
with a presidential election
the constitution says that the vice
president of the united states
oversees the process of counting the
electoral college votes
a process
that took place on january 6 2021
donald trump wanted mike pence
to do something no other vice president
has ever done
the former president wanted pence to
reject the votes and either declare
trump the winner or send the votes back
to the states to be counted again
mike pence said no
he resisted the pressure
he knew it was illegal he knew it was
wrong
we are fortunate for mr pence's courage
on january 6th
our democracy came dangerously close to
catastrophe
that courage put him in tremendous
danger
when mike pence made it clear
that he wouldn't give in to donald
trump's scheme
donald trump turned the mob on him
a mob that was chanting hang mike pence
a mob that had built a hangman's gallows
just outside the capitol
thanks in part to mike pence our
democracy was stood donald trump's
scheme
and the violence of january 6th
but the danger hasn't receded
led by my colleague mr aguilar
today we'll lay out the facts for the
american people
but first i recognize my colleague from
wyoming miss cheney for any opening
statement she care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman let me
take just a few minutes today to put the
topic of our hearing in broader context
in our last hearing we heard unequivocal
testimony that president trump was told
his election fraud allegations were
complete nonsense we heard this from
members of the trump campaign
we heard this from president trump's
campaign lawyers
we heard this from president trump's
former attorney general bill barr
we heard this from president trump's
former acting attorney general jeff
rosen
and we heard this from president trump's
former acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue
we heard from members of president
trump's white house staff as well
today we're focusing on president
trump's relentless effort to pressure
mike pence to refuse to count electoral
votes on january 6.
here again is how the former vice
president phrased it in a speech before
the federalist society a group of
conservative lawyers
this week
that president trump said i had the
right to
overturn the election
president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
america
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
what the president wanted the vice
president to do was not just wrong it
was illegal and unconstitutional
we will hear many details in today's
hearing but please consider these two
points first
president trump was told repeatedly
that mike pence lacked the
constitutional and legal authority to do
what president trump was demanding he do
this is testimony from mark short the
vice president's chief of staff
who served in the trump administration
in multiple positions over four years
but just to pick up on that mr short is
it was it your impression that the vice
president had directly conveyed his
position on these issues to the
president not just to the world through
a dear colleague letter but directly to
president trump many times
and he'd been consistent in conveying
his position to the president very
consistent okay
but president trump plotted with a
lawyer named john eastman to pressure
pence to do so anyway
as the federal court has explained quote
based on the evidence the court finds
that it is more likely than not that
president trump and dr eastman
dishonestly conspired to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
what exactly did president trump know
when exactly did president trump know
that it would be illegal for mike pence
to refuse to count electoral votes
here is one sample of testimony given by
one of the witnesses before us today the
vice president's general counsel
did john eastman ever
admit
you know in front of the president
that his proposal would violate the
electoral account act
uh
i believe he did on the fourth
that was january 4th
two days before the attack on congress
a second point
please listen to testimony today about
all of the ways that president trump
attempted to pressure vice president
pence
including
donald trump's tweet at 2 24 pm
condemning vice president mike pence
when president trump already knew a
violent riot was underway at the capitol
in future hearings you will hear from
witnesses who were present inside the
white house who were present inside the
west wing on that day
but today we focus on the earnest
efforts of mike pence who was determined
to abide by his oath of office
as vice president pence prepared a
statement on january 5th and 6th
explaining that he could not illegally
refuse to count electoral votes he said
this to his staff
i mean the vice president said this may
be the most important thing i ever said
this meaning statement
he really wanted to make sure
that it was just seven
you will hear today that president
trump's white house counsel believed
that the vice president did exactly the
right thing on january 6th as did others
in the white house
as did fox news host sean hannity
vice president pence understood that his
oath of office was more important than
his loyalty to donald trump
he did his duty
president trump unequivocally did not
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection i recognize the
gentleman from california
mr aguilar for an opening statement
thank you mr chairman
today we intend to show the american
people that january 6th was not an
isolated incident in the weeks
culminating before
it was a legal scheme
and deception
we've already learned that president
trump knew he lost the 2020 election
shortly after he began to look for a way
to circumvent our country's most
fundamental civic tradition
the peaceful transfer of power
the president latched on to a dangerous
theory
and would not let go
because he was convinced it would keep
him in office
we witnessed firsthand what happened
when the president of the united states
weaponized this theory
the capital was overrun
police officers lost their lives
and the vice president was taken to a
secure location
because his safety was in jeopardy
let's take a look at the effect of
donald trump's words and actions
i want to warn our audience that the
video contains explicit content
mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a a sad day for our country
and mike pence i hope you're going to
stand up for the good of our
constitution and for the good of our
country and if you're not i'm going to
be very disappointed in you i will tell
you right now
i'm telling you what i'm hearing the
pence
i hear in the pins just caved no
is that true i didn't i'm here i'm
hearing reports that pence cave
i'm telling you if pence came we're
gonna drag [ __ ] through the
streets
you [ __ ] politicians are gonna get
[ __ ] drug through the streets i guess
the hope is that there's such a show of
force here that pence will
decide to just do the right thing
according to him
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how did we get to this point
how did we get to the point where
president trump's most radical
supporters
led a violent attack on the capitol and
threatened to hang president trump's own
vice president
you'll hear from witnesses that donald
trump pressured mike pence to adopt a
legally and morally bankrupt idea that
the vice president could choose who the
next president can be
you'll hear about how the vice president
the white house counsel and others told
donald trump that the vice president had
no such authority
but president trump would not listen
you'll hear how vice president pence was
stood in onslaught of pressure from
president trump both publicly and
privately
a pressure campaign that built to a
fever pitch with a heated phone call on
january 6th
you'll also hear
that the president knew there was a
violent mob at the capitol when he
tweeted at 2 24 p.m that the vice
president did not have the quote courage
to do what needed to be done
let me be clear
vice president pence did the right thing
that day
he stayed true to his oath to protect
and defend the constitution
i look forward to hearing from our
witnesses this afternoon
mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr aguilar
we are honored to have two distinguished
witnesses
who advise vice president regarding his
role
on january 6th
judge j michael ludick is one of the
leading conservative legal thinkers in
the country
he served in administrations of
president ronald reagan and george h.w
bush
he was appointed by the latter to serve
on the u.s court of appeals for the
fourth circuit where he served from 1991
to 2006.
he provided critical advice for vice
president pence regarding the role of
the vice president in the joint session
of congress shortly before that fateful
moment
he's written that the vice president
does not have the power
to select the next president of the
united states
he's also written that con that contrary
theory espoused by one of his own former
law clerks was quote
incorrect at every turn
we're also joined today by one of the
people who was with vice president pence
on january 6th
greg jacob
was counsel to vice president pence he
conducted a thorough analysis of the
role of the vice president in the joint
session of congress under the
constitution
the electoral account act and 230 years
of historical practice
but he also has firsthand information
about the attack on the capitol
because he lived through it
he was with the vice president and his
own life was in danger
i will now swear in our witnesses
the witnesses will please stand and
raise their right hand
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
let the record reflect the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
i don't recognize myself for questions
in the united states the people choose
our representatives
including the highest official in the
land the president of the united states
the american people did this on november
3rd 2020
but president trump did not like the
outcome
he did everything he could to change the
result of the election
he tried litigation
62 cases in fact and that failed
he tried to pressure state legislatures
to reverse the results of the election
in their states
but they refused he tried to enlist the
department of justice in his efforts to
overturn election results
but officials leading the department
refused to comply
so eventually he latched on to a
completely nonsensical and
anti-democratic theory
that one man
his own vice president could determine
the outcome of the election
he wanted the vice president to
unilaterally select
the president
this theory that the vice president
could unilaterally select the president
runs completely contrary to our
constitution
our laws and the
entirety of our american experience but
that didn't stop
didn't matter to president trump
i would now like to explore
how president trump came to latch on to
this ridiculous legal theory
that the vice president can select the
president of the united states
mr jacob
how did this theory first come to your
attention
the first time that i had a conversation
with the vice president about the 12th
amendment and the electoral count act
was in early december around december
7th
the vice president called me over to his
west wing office and told me that he had
been
seeing and reading things that suggested
that he had a significant role to play
on january 6th
in announcing the outcome of the
election
he told me that he had been first
elected to congress in 2000 and that one
of his earliest memories as a
congressman was sitting in
on the 2001 certification
and he recalled that al gore
had gaveled down a number of objections
that had been raised to florida
and he asked me
um
mechanically how does this work at the
joint session what are the rules and i
told the vice president that um in fact
i had a fairly good idea of how things
work that actually there aren't rules
that govern the joint session but what
there is
is a
provision of the constitution that's
just one sentence long and then an
electoral count act that had been passed
in 1887
and i told the vice president that i
could put a memo together for him
overnight that would explain the
applicable rules
so mr jacobs when you looked at this
theory
what did you conclude
so
we concluded that
what you have is a sentence in the
constitution that is inartfully drafted
but the vice president's first instinct
when he heard this theory
was that there was no way
that our framers who aboard concentrated
power who had broken away from the
tyranny of george iii
would ever
have put
one person particularly not a person who
had a direct interest in the outcome
because they were on the ticket for the
election
in a role to have decisive
impact on the outcome of the election
and
our review of text
history
and frankly just common sense all
confirmed the vice president's first
instinct on that point there is no
uh justifiable basis to conclude that
the vice president has that kind of
authority
thank you mr jacobs
we will hear more today about how
despite this conclusion by you and other
top
legal advisors the former president used
this discredited theory
in his campaign to pressure the vice
president
to decide the outcome of the
presidential election
i now recognize the gentlewoman from
wyoming miss cheney for questions
thank you very much uh mr chairman um
judge ludwig thank you as well for being
here with us today um
you um
issued a very important statement
earlier today uh which
i urge all americans to read
and i'd like to ask you judge about
one of the sentences in your statement
and ask if you could explain to us
the significance of it
you say had the vice president of the
united states obeyed the president of
the united states
america would immediately have been
plunged into what would have been
tantamount to a revolution within a
paralyzing constitutional crisis could
you elaborate on that for us judge
thank you
madam
vice chairman
um
that that passage in in my statement
this morning
uh
referenced the
the most foundational
concept
in america which is the rule of law
thus as i interpret your question
you're asking about
that foundational
truth
of these
united states
which we call america
the foundational
truth
is the rule of law
that foundational
truth
is
for the united states of america
the profound
truth
but it's not merely
the profound truth
for the united states
it's also
the simple
truth
the simple foundational truth
of the american republic
thus
in my view
the hearings being conducted
by this
select committee
are
examining that
profound truth
namely the rule of law
in the united states of america
the specific question of course before
you
and before the nation
not before me
is whether
that
foundational rule of law
was supremely violated
on january 6
2021
now
to the question specifically that you
asked
madam vice chair
i believe that
had
vice presidents pence
obeyed the orders
from his president
and the president of the united states
of america
during the joint session
of the congress of the united states
on
january 6
2021
and
declared
donald trump
the next
president of the united states
notwithstanding
that
then president trump
had
lost the electoral college vote
as well as the
popular vote in the 2020 presidential
election
that declaration of donald trump as the
next president
would have
plunged america
into what
i
believe
would have been tantamount
to a
revolution
within
a constitutional crisis
in america
which in my view
and i'm only one man
would have been
the first
constitutional crisis
since the founding of the republic
thank you very much judge um for your
solemn attention to these issues
and and for your
appearance here today
um we're gonna describe and discuss in
detail
what happened
and as we do i'm going to describe a few
of the details now
of some of the actions taken
by a gentleman named kenneth
cheeseborough
after the
electoral college met
and cast their votes on december 14th
actually the day before they met kenneth
chesbro sent a memo to rudy giuliani the
president's lead outside council
mr cheeseborough wrote to mayor giuliani
that the vice president is charged with
quote
making judgments about what to do if
there are conflicting votes close quote
mr cheeseborough wrote that when the
joint session of congress got to arizona
in the alphabetical list of states the
vice president should not count
the biden votes quote because there are
two slates of votes
his justification which we will learn
more about in our next hearing was that
a group of trump supporters in arizona
and other swing states
decided to proclaim themselves the true
electors for the state
creating two sets of electors
the official electors selected by the
state
and a group of fake electors
this document was ordered to be produced
to the select committee by a federal
district court judge
as you will see on the screen shortly
judge david carter wrote quote
the draft memo pushed a strategy that
knowingly violated the electoral count
act
the judge concluded that quote the memo
is both intimately related to and
clearly advanced the plan
to obstruct the joint session of
congress on january 6 2021
a few days later professor john eastman
took up this cause
eastman was at the time a law professor
at chapman university law school
he prepared a memo outlining the
nonsensical theory that the vice
president could decide the outcome of
the election at the joint session of
congress on january 6th
you will see
portions of this memo on the screen
in the first line
he wrote quote seven states have
transmitted dual slates of electors to
the president of the senate
but dr eastman goes on to rely on those
so-called dual slates of electors to say
that vice president pence could simply
declare president trump the winner of
the 2020 election
mr jacob were there in fact dual slates
of electors from seven states no there
were not
and just a few days after that dr
eastman wrote another memo this one
quote wore gaming out several scenarios
he knew the outcome he wanted and he saw
a way to go forward
if he simply pretended that fake
electors were real
you will see that memo up on
the screen now
here dr eastman says the vice president
can reject the biden electors from the
states that he calls quote disputed
under several of the scenarios the vice
president could ultimately just declare
donald trump the winner
regardless of the vote totals that had
already been certified by the states
however this was false
and dr eastman knew it was false
in other words it was a lie
in fact on december 19 2020 just four
days before dr eastman sent this memo
dr eastman himself admitted in an email
that the fake electors had no legal
weight
referring to the fake electors is quote
dead on arrival in congress
end quote
because they did not have a
certification from their states
judge ludig did the trump electors in
those seven states who were not
certified by any state authority have
any legal significance
congresswoman there there was um
no support
whatsoever
in either the constitution of the united
states
nor the laws of the united states
for
the vice president
frankly
ever
to count
alternative electoral slates from the
states
that had not been
officially certified
by the designated
state official
in the electoral count act
of 1887
i did notice
in
the passage from
mr eastman's memorandum
and i took a note on it
and correct me if i'm wrong
but
he said
in that passage
that there was
both legal authority
as well as
historical
precedent
i do know what
mr eastman was referring to
when he said that there was
historical precedent
for doing so
he was incorrect
there was no
historical precedent
from the beginning
of the founding
in 1789
that
even as
mere historical precedent
as distinguished from
legal precedent
would support
the possibility of the vice president of
the united states
quote counting
alternative electoral slates that had
not been officially certified
to the congress
were suing to the electoral count act of
1887.
i
would be glad
to
explain that historical precedent
if the committee
wanted but it would be a digression
you very much judge
i know my colleagues will be pursuing
that issue in more depth uh and now i'd
like to yield back mr chairman
thank you very much pursuant to section
5 5c 8 of house resolution 503. the
chair recognizes gentlemen from
california mr aguilar and staff council
mr john wood for questioning
thank you mr chairman
we're fortunate to have a bipartisan
staff
senior investigative counsel john wood
previously served as united states
attorney
in missouri under president george w
bush he and i will share today's lines
of questioning mr wood thank you mr
aguilar
uh judge ludwig i had the incredible
honor of serving as one of your law
clerks
another person who did
was john eastman
and you've written that dr eastman's
that the vice president could determine
who the next president united states is
is in your words
incorrect at every turn
could you please explain briefly your
analysis
it was my honor
mr wood
to have you serve with my walker
i i couldn't answer that question
perfectly
if i had
at my disposal
either
mr eastman's
tweet
or my own
analytical tweet of september 21st
but i don't
but um
that said let me try to
um
remember the
analysis of
mr eastman's analysis
and judge i can read to you and to the
audience i think what was a really key
passage from your very insightful
analysis when you wrote i believed that
professor eastman was incorrect at every
turn of the analysis in his january
second memorandum beginning with his
claim that there were legitimate
competing slates of electors presented
from seven states and you've already
addressed that issue but your next
sentence said continuing to his
conclusion that the vice president could
unilaterally decide not to count the
votes from the seven states from which
competing slates were allegedly
presented so what was your basis for
concluding that dr eastman was incorrect
in his conclusion that the vice
president could unilaterally decide not
to count the votes from these disputed
states
i understand
as i previously
stated in response to
congresswoman cheney
the
there was no
basis in the constitution or laws of the
united states
at all
for the theory espoused
by mr eastman
at all
none
with all respect to
my co-panelist
he said i believe in
partial response to one of the select
committee's questions
that the single sentence in the
12th amendment
was he thought inartfully written
that single sentence is not
in artfully written
it was
pristine
clear
that the
president of the senate
on january 6
the incumbent vice president of the
united states
had little
substantive constitutional authority
if any
at all
the 12th amendment
the single sentence
that mr jacob refers to
says
in substance
that
following the transmission of the
certificates
to the
congress of the united states
and under the
electoral count act of 1887
the archivist of the united states
that
the presiding
officer
shall
open
the certificates
in the presence
of the congress of the united states in
joint session
it then
says
unmistakably
not even that the
vice president
himself
shall
count the electoral votes
it clearly says
merely
that
the electoral count votes
shall then be counted
it was the
electoral account act of 1887
that
um
that filled in if you will
uh
the
simple words of
of the 12th amendment
in order to
construct for the country
uh
a
process for the counting of the
the sacred
process
for the counting of the electoral
votes
from the states
that neither
our original constitution
nor even
the 12th amendment
had done
the
irony if you will
is that
from its founding
until 1887
in
when
congress passed the electoral count act
um
the nation had been in
considerable
turmoil
during
at least five of its presidential
elections
beginning
as soon
thereafter
from the founding
as eighteen hundred
so it wasn't for
almost a hundred years later
until the electoral count act was passed
so
[Music]
that's why in my view
that piece of legislation
uh
is
not only a work in progress
for the country
but at this moment in history
an important
work in progress that needs to take
place
that was
long-winded i understand
judge ludwig at the risk of
oversimplifying for the non-lawyers who
are watching is it fair to say that the
12th amendment basically says two things
happen the vice president opens the
certificates and the electoral votes are
counted is it that straightforward
i would not want that
to be my testimony before
the congress of the united states
the language
of the 12th amendment
is that simple
thank you judge
mr jacob i have a question for you
i believe during your deposition before
this committee
you said something to the effect of
you'd read every word written about the
12th amendment the electoral account act
and historical practice
i know in response to the chairman's
earlier question you gave your bottom
line conclusion but can you tell us a
little bit about the process that you
and your colleagues went through
of researching this issue and what
conclusion you came to after your
thorough research
so
you as a lawyer who's analyzing a
constitutional provision you start with
the constitutional text you go to
structure
you go to history so we started with the
text
we did not think that the text was quite
as unambiguous as judge ludig indicated
in part
we had a constitutional crisis in 1876
because in that year
multiple slates of electors were
certified by multiple slates
and when it came time to count those
votes
the antecedent question of which ones
had to be answered
that required the appointment of an
independent commission
that commission had had to resolve that
question and the purpose of the
electoral can act of 1887
had been to resolve those latent
ambiguities now i'm in complete
agreement with judge ludwig
it is unambiguous that the vice
president does not have the authority to
reject electors there is no suggestion
of any kind that it does
there is no mention of rejecting or
objecting to electors anywhere in the
12th amendment
um and so the notion that the vice
president could do that certainly is not
in the text but the problem
that we had and that john eastman raised
in our discussions was
we had all seen that in congress in 2000
in 2004 in 2016
there had been objections raised to
various states
and those had even been debated in 2004
and so
here you have an amendment that says
nothing about objecting or rejecting and
yet we did have some recent practice of
that happening within the terms of the
electoral count end so
we started with that text and i recalled
in my discussion with the vice president
he said
i can't wait to go to heaven and meet
the framers and tell them
the work that you did in putting
together our constitution is a work of
genius thank you it was divinely
inspired
there is one sentence that i would like
to talk to you a little bit about
so then we went to structure and again
the vice president's first instinct here
is so decisive on this question there's
just no way that the framers of the
constitution who divided power and
authority who separated it out
who
um had broken away from george iii
and declared him to be a tyrant there
was no way that they would have put in
the hands of one person the authority to
determine
who was going to be president of the
united states
and then we went to history we examined
every single electoral vote
count that had happened in congress
since the beginning of the country
we examined the electoral count act we
examined practice under the electoral
candidate and critically
no vice president in 230 years of
history had ever claimed to have that
kind of authority hadn't claimed
authority to reject electoral votes had
not claimed authority to return
electoral votes back to the states in
the entire history of the united states
not once had a joint session ever
returned electoral votes back to the
states to be counted
and in the
crisis of 1876
justice bradley
of the united states supreme court who
supplied the decisive final vote on that
commission had specifically looked at
that question and said
first the vice president clearly doesn't
have authority to decide anything and by
the way also does not have authority to
conduct an investigation by sending
things back out
for a public look at things so
the history was
absolutely decisive and again part of my
discussion with mr eastman was if you
were right don't you think al gore might
have liked to have known in 2000 that he
had authority to just declare himself
president of the united states did you
think that the democrat lawyers just
didn't think of this very obvious quirk
that he could use to do that and of
course he acknowledged al gore
did not and should not have had that
authority at that point in time but so
text structure history i think what we
had was some ambiguous text
that common sense and structure would
tell you the answer cannot possibly be
that the vice president has that
authority as the committee already
played the vice president's remarks
there is almost no idea more un-american
than the notion that any one person
would choose the american president and
then unbroken historical practice for
230 years that the vice president did
not have such an authority
thank you i reserve the remainder of my
time
mr jacob you weren't the only one
who knew that the legal theory was wrong
though
here's what various advisors to the
president thought about that theory
you've been clear repeatedly with mr
meadows about you and the vice president
having a different view about his
authority on january 6 i believe i had
did mr meadows ever explicitly or
tacitly agree with you or say yeah that
makes sense okay
i believe that um
that mark did agree
what makes you say that
i believe that's what he told me
but
as i mentioned i think mark had told so
many people so many different things
that it was not something that uh that i
would necessarily
accept is okay well that means that's
resolved i say tell me more what he told
you about on this topic well i think it
was that you know the vice president
doesn't have any broader role
and i think he was understanding that so
despite the fact that he may have said
other things to the president or others
to you he said he understands the vice
president has no role yes okay did he
say that to you several times a couple
of times
before january 6th yes
the way it was communicated to me was
that
um uh paso bologna
thought the idea
was uh
was nutty and had uh at what point
uh confronted eastman uh basically with
the same sentiment
pat expressed that his admiration for
the vice president's actions on the day
of the sixth and said that he concurred
with the legal analysis that that our
team had put together to reach
that point
it made no sense to me
that in all the protections that were
built into the constitution
for a president to get elected in steps
that had to be taken
that the power to choose the next
president would be sitting at with the
vice president
do you know if mr clark or mr
um
morgan it's important
viewed about that thought about that mr
eastman's advice yeah they thought he
was crazy
do you know if they ever expressed an
opinion on whether they thought the vice
president had the power that john
eastman said he did
uh
i know for a fact i heard both say that
his theory was crazy that there was no
validity to in any way shape or form
and did they express that before january
6th
yes
to whom
i think anyone who would listen
okay uh what were your prior
interactions with eastman
he described for me
what he thought the ambiguity was in the
statute and he was walking through it at
that time and i said
hold on a second i want to understand
what you're saying you're saying that
you believe the vice president acting as
president of the senate
can be the sole decision maker as to
under your theory who becomes the next
president united states
and
he said yes
i said are you out of your f in mind
right and i
know
that was pretty blunt
i said you're completely crazy i said
you're going to turn around
and tell
78 plus million people in this country
that your
theory is this is how you're going to
invalidate their votes because you think
the election was stolen
and i said they're not going to tolerate
that said you're going to cause riots in
the streets and he said
words to the effect of there's been
violence in the history of our country
eric to protect the democracy or protect
the republic
in fact there was a risk that the
lawyers in the white house counsel's
office would resign
for example fox news host sean hannity
expressed concern that the entire white
house counsel's office could quit
as you can see from these texts
mr hannity wrote to white house chief of
staff mark meadows that quote we can't
lose the entire white house counsel's
office i do not see january 6 happening
the way he is being told
a few days later on january 5th mr
hannity wrote to mr meadows that quote
i'm very worried the next 48 hours
pence pressure white house counsel will
leave while sean hannity was apparently
very concerned about the possibility
that the white house council would
resign in protest
the president's effort to force the vice
president to violate the constitution
some others close to the president were
more dismissive of the white house
counsel's position
here's what trump's son-in-law and
senior adviser jared kushner said
during his
deposition regarding white house counsel
pat sipoloni's threats to resign
jared uh are you aware of um instances
where uh pat cipolloni threatened to
resign i i kind of like i said my
interest at that time was on trying to
get as many pardons done
and i know that you know he was always
him and the team were always saying oh
we're going to resign we're not going to
be here if this happens if that happens
so
i kind of took it up to just be whining
to be honest with you
the president's own lead outside council
rudy giuliani also seemed to concede
that the vice president did not have the
authority to decide the outcome of the
election or send it back to the states
here's what white house attorney eric
hershman said about his call with mayor
giuliani on the morning of the sixth
the morning of january 6 i think he
called me out of the blue
right and i was like getting dressed
and
we had an intellectual discussion that
about
eastman's east i don't know if it's
eastman's theory per se but the vp is
role
and
you know he it was asking me my view and
analysis and then the practical
implications of it
and when we finished
he said
like i believe that you know you're
probably right
i think he thought were done that it
would be something he'd have to consider
if he was sitting on the bench but he'd
probably come down and that you know
you couldn't interpret it or sustain the
argument long term
of course the fact that mayor giuliani
seemed to admit that the theory was
wrong did not stop him from going before
the crowd just a few hours later on
january 6th and sang the exact opposite
here's mayor giuliani's speech at the
ellipse rally on january 6th
we're here uh just very briefly to make
a very important
two points
number one
every single thing
that has been outlined
as the plan for today is perfectly legal
i have professor eastman here with me to
say a few words about that
he's one of the preeminent
constitutional scholars in the united
states
it is perfectly appropriate
given the questionable constitutionality
of the
election
counting act of 1887
that the vice president can cast it
aside
and he can do what
a president called jefferson did
when he was vice president
he can decide
he can decide on the validity
of these crooked ballots
or he can send it back
to the legislatures
give them
5
to ten days to finally finish
the work
and here's what dr eastman said in his
speech at the ellipse
on january 6th
and all we are demanding of vice
president pence is this afternoon at one
o'clock he let the legislatures of the
state look into this so we get to the
bottom of it and the american people
know whether we have control of the
direction of our government or not
[Applause]
even dr eastman knew his theory didn't
hold water
mr jacob
you discussed and even debated this
theory at length with dr eastman
did dr eastman ever tell you what he
thought the u.s supreme court would do
if it had to decide this issue
yes
um
we had an extended discussion an hour
and a half to two hours on january 5th
and
when i pressed him on the point i said
john
if the vice president did what you were
asking him to do we would lose nine to
nothing in the supreme court wouldn't we
and
he initially started well i think maybe
you would lose only seven to two
um and after some further discussion
acknowledged well yeah you're right we
would lose nine nothing
i appreciate that in our investigation
the select committee has obtained
evidence suggesting that dr eastman
never really believed his own theory
let me explain
on the screen you can see a draft letter
to the president from october
2020.
in this letter an idea was proposed that
the vice president could determine which
electors to count at the joint session
of congress
but the person writing in blue
eviscerates that argument
the person who wrote the comments in
blue wrote
the 12th amendment only says that the
president of the senate opens the
ballots in the joint session and then
in the passive voice that the vote shall
then be counted
the comments in blue further state
nowhere does it suggest that the
president of the senate gets to make the
determination on his own
judge looting does it surprise you that
the author of those comments in blue was
in fact john eastman
yes it does congressman
but let me
watching
this unfold
let me try to unpack
what was
at the root
of
what i have called the blueprint to
overturn the 2020 election
and it is this
and i had foreshadowed this answer
in my earlier
testimony
to congresswoman cheney
mr eastman
from the beginning
said to the president
that there was both legal
as well as
historical precedent
for the vice president
to overturn the election
and what we've heard today
i believe
is is what happened within the white
house and elsewhere
as
all the
the players
led by
mr eastman
got wrapped around the axle
by the
historical
evidence claim
by mr eastman
let me explain very simply
this is what i said would require a
digression that i would be glad to
undertake if you wished
in short
if i had been advising the vice
president of the united states on
january 6th
and even if
then
vice president
jefferson
and
even then
vice president
john adams
and even
then
vice president
richard
nixon
had done
exactly
what the president of the united states
wanted his vice president to do
i would have laid my body
across the road before
i would have let
the vice president
overturn the
2020 election
on the basis
of that
historical precedent
but what
this body needs to know
and now
america needs to know
is that
that was
the centerpiece
of the plan to overturn the 2020
election it was the historical
precedent
in the years
and with the vice presidents that i i
named
as congressman raskin understands well
and
the
the effort by mr eastman and others was
to
to drive that
historical precedent
up to and under
that single
sentence
single pristine
sentence
in the 12th amendment to the united
states constitution
taking advantage of if you will
what many
have said
is the in artful wording
of that sentence in the 12th amendment
scholars
before 2020
would have used that historic old
precedent
to argue not that vice president pence
could overturn the 2020 election
by accepting
non-certified state electoral votes
but they would have
made arguments as to some
substantive
not merely
procedural
authority
possessed by the vice president of the
united states on on
the
statutorily prescribed day for counting
the electoral college votes
this is um
this is constitutional mischief
judge i think that's a i think there's a
good point and i think it kind of begs
the question
that if the vice president had this
power to determine the outcome of a
presidential election why hasn't it ever
been used before why hasn't that ever
happened why hasn't a vice president
simply rejected the outcome of an
election and declared someone else the
winner
and instead as the chairman mentioned in
his opening for over two centuries vice
presidents have presided over the joint
sessions of congress in a purely
ceremonial role
this even includes as mr jacob mentioned
vice president al gore for those of us
who are old enough to remember
the 2000 election came down to one state
florida
there were weeks of recounts and
litigation after the election and al
gore conceded
of course al gore was vice president at
the time
united over the counting of the
electoral votes
let's hear what vice president gore said
when he described the situation he faced
in 2000
importance of the united states of
america in all of human history
in lincoln's phrase we still are the
last best hope of humankind
uh and
the choice between one's own
disappointment in your personal career
and upholding the
the noble traditions of america's
democracy it's a pretty easy choice when
it comes down to it
mr jacob
did dr eastman say whether he would want
other vice presidents such as al gore
after the 2000 election or kamala harris
after the 2024 election to have the
power to decide the outcome of the of
the election
so this was one of the many points that
we discussed on january 5th
he had come into that meeting trying to
persuade us that there was some validity
to his theory i viewed it as my
objective to persuade him
to acknowledge he was just wrong and i
thought this had to be one of the most
powerful
arguments i mean john
back in 2000
you weren't jumping up and saying al
gore had this authority to do that you
would not want kamala harris to be able
to exercise that kind of authority in
2024 when i hope republicans will win
the election and i know you hope that
too john and he said
absolutely al gore did not have a basis
to do it in 2000 kamala harris shouldn't
be able to do it in 2024
but i think you should do it today
mark short told the select committee
that vice president pence consulted with
one of his predecessors vice president
dan quayle regarding the role of the
vice president
vice president quayle confirmed pence's
view that the role was purely ceremonial
mr short also told the committee that he
mr short received a call from former
house speaker paul ryan
here is mr short's description of his
conversation with speaker ryan
speaker ryan wanted to call and say you
know you don't have
any greater authority and i i said and
mr speaker you you know mike you know he
doesn't you know he recognizes that and
we sort of laughed about it and he said
i get it and he later spoke to um the
vice president too to i think have the
same conversation
fortunately for the fate of our republic
vice president pence refused to go along
with president trump's demands that he
determined the outcome of the
presidential election
mr jacob what was the vice president's
reaction when you discussed with him the
theory that the vice president could
decide the outcome of the election
congressman as i testified the vice
president's first instinct uh was that
there was no way
that any one person particularly the
vice president who is on the ticket and
has a vested outcome in the election
could possibly have the authority to
decide it by rejecting electors or
to decisively alter the outcome by
suspending the joint session for the
first time in history in order to try to
get a different outcome from state
legislatures
despite the fact that the vice president
had a strongly held and correct view
that he could not decide the outcome of
the election
president trump launched a multi-week
campaign
of both public and private pressure
to get the vice president mike pence to
violate the constitution
here are some examples of the intense
pressure the vice president faced from
all sides and what his chief of staff
thought of it
i hope mike pence comes through for us i
have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through
i won't like him quite as much
was it your impression that the vice
president had directly conveyed his
position on these issues to the
president not just to the world through
a dear colleague letter but directly to
president trump many times
and he'd been consistent in conveying
his position to the president very
consistent
i am i am aware of the fact that the
president was upset
with the way
uh pence acted
right are we to assume that this is
going to be a climactic battle well i
think a lot of that depends on the
courage and the spine of the individuals
involved that would be a nice way to say
a guy named mike uh vice president mike
pence
yes
i think we've been clear is what the
vice president's role is i think the
vice president made clear with the
president i think i've been clear with
mark mose i think the vice president is
going to throw down tomorrow and do the
right thing because like i said before
this is a time for choosing people are
going to look back at this moment
tomorrow and remember where every single
one of their elected officials were did
they vote for the rule of law and
getting these elections right or did
they give it away to the democrats and
the people who cheated and stole their
way through this election definitely in
the you know i got back into town to
talk to like the the fifth and the sixth
um the president was you know all the
attention was
on uh what mike would do or what mike
wouldn't do the vice president really
was not wavering in his commitment to
what he what his responsibility was and
so yeah was it
was it painful sure
the president's pressure campaign
started in december
for example although the vice president
made his views clearly and unmistakably
known to the president and others in the
white house on december 23rd
president trump retweeted a memo from an
individual named ivan reichlen entitled
operation pence card
that called on the vice president to
refuse the electoral college votes from
certain states that had certified joe
biden as the winner
president trump started his pressure
campaign in december
but he dialed up the pressure as january
6th approached
the testimony we have received in our
investigation indicates that by the time
january 4th arrived president trump had
already engaged in a quote multi-week
campaign
to pressure the vice president to decide
the outcome of the election
this had included private conversations
between the two leaders
trump's tweets and at least one meeting
with members of congress
we understand that the vice president
started his day on january 4th with a
rally in georgia for the republican
candidates in the u.s senate runoff
when the vice president returned to
washington he was summoned to meet with
the president regarding the upcoming
joint session of congress
mr jacob who attended that meeting
the attendees were the vice president
the president
mark short the chief of staff to the
vice president myself and john eastman
there was about a five minute period
where mark meadows came in on a
different issue
let's show a photo of that meeting
mr jacob
during that meeting between the
president and the vice president what
theories did dr eastman present
regarding the role of the vice president
in counting the electoral votes
during the meeting on january 4th
mr eastman was opining that there were
two legally viable arguments
as to
authorities that the vice president
could exercise
two days later on january 6th
one of them
was that he could
reject electoral votes outright
the other was that he could use his
capacity as presiding officer to
suspend the proceedings
and declare essentially a 10-day recess
during which
states that he deemed to be disputed
there was a list of five to seven states
that
um the exact number changed from
conversation to conversation
but that the vice president could
issue a demand to the state legislatures
in those states to re-examine
the election and declare
who had won each of those states so he
said that both of those were legally
viable options um he said that he did
not recommend um upon questioning he did
not recommend what he called the more
aggressive option which was reject
outright because he thought that that
would be
less politically palatable
the the imperimeter
of state legislature authority
would be necessary to ultimately
have
uh public acceptance of an outcome in
favor of president trump and so he
advocated that the preferred course of
action would be the procedural route
of suspending the joint session and
sending the election back to the states
mr jacob i know you won't discuss the
direct conversations between the
president and the vice president so
rather than asking you what the vice
president said in that meeting i'll ask
you a more general question did the vice
president ever waver in his position
that he could not unilaterally decide
which electors to accept
the vice president never budged from the
position that i have described as his
first instinct which was
that it just made no sense from
everything that he knew and had studied
about our constitution that one person
would have that kind of authority and
did the vice president ever waver in his
position that he could not delay
certification and send it back to the
states
no he did not
did dr eastman admit in front of the
president that his proposal would
violate the electoral account act
so during that meeting on the 4th
um i think i
raised the problem that
both of mr eastman's proposals would
violate several provisions of the
electoral count act
mr eastman acknowledged that that was
the case um that
even what he viewed as the more
politically palatable option would
violate several provisions
but he thought that we could do so
because in his view the electoral can
act was unconstitutional
and when i raised concerns that that
position would likely lose in court his
view was that the court simply wouldn't
get involved they would invoke the
political question doctrine
um and therefore we could have some
comfort proceeding
with that path
mr wood but just to reiterate he told
you
maybe this was in a later conversation
but he told you at some point that if in
fact the issue ever got to the supreme
court
his theory would lose 9-0 correct
the next morning
starting around 11 or 11 30 we met for
an hour and a half to two hours and in
that meeting
um
i've already described the text
structure history conversation but we
started walking through all of that and
i said
john basically what you have is
some text that may be a little bit
ambiguous but then
nothing else that would support it
including the fact that nobody would
ever want that to be the rule
wouldn't we lose nine to nothing in the
supreme court and again he
initially started well maybe you'd only
lose seven to two but ultimately
acknowledged
that no we would lose nine zero no judge
would support his argument
after his meeting with the vice
president donald trump flew to georgia
for a rally in support of the republican
candidates in the united states senate
runoff
even though the vice president
was had been steadfast in resisting the
president's pressure
president trump continued to publicly
pressure vice president pence in his
georgia speech
rather than focusing exclusively on the
georgia senate runoff
trump turned his attention to mike pence
here's what the president said during
that rally in georgia
hence comes through for us i have to
tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through
i won't like him quite as much
so the president had been told multiple
times that the vice president could not
affect the outcome of the election
but he nonetheless publicly pressured
mike pence to do exactly that
by saying quote if he doesn't come
through i won't like him as much
let's turn now to january 5th
mr wood
thank you
that morning meaning january 5th
the president issued a tweet expressly
stating that the vice president had the
power to reject electors let's look at
what the president wrote
quote the vice president has the power
to reject fraudulently chosen electors
mr jacob you've already told us about
your meeting with dr eastman and the
president on january 4th
and you briefly made reference to the
meeting you had with dr eastman the next
day january 5th can you tell us a little
bit more about that meeting with dr
eastman on january 5th for example
where was the meeting who was there
so at the
conclusion of the meeting on the fourth
the president had asked that um
that our office
meet with uh mr eastman the next day to
hear more
about the positions he had expressed at
that meeting and the vice president
indicated that
um
offered me up as his counsel uh to
fulfill that duty so we met in mark
short's office in the executive office
building
across the way from the white house
um
dr eastman had a
court hearing by zoom that morning so it
didn't start first thing but rather
started around 11
and
that meeting went for about an hour and
a half two hours
chief of staff mark short was
at that meeting most of the time there
were a few times that he uh left
and essentially it was an extended
discussion um
what most surprised me about that
meeting was that when mr eastman came in
he
said
i'm here to request that you reject the
electors
so
on the fourth
that had been the path that he had said
i'm not recommending that you do that
but on the fifth
he came in and
expressly requested that and
i grabbed a notebook as i was heading
into the meeting
i didn't hear much new from him to
record but that was the first thing i
recorded
in my notes was
request that the vp reject
just to be clear
you're saying that dr eastman urged the
vice president to adopt the very same
approach
that dr eastman appeared to abandon in
the oval office meeting with the
president the day before is that correct
he had recommended against it the
evening before and then on the fifth
came in and i think it was probably his
first words after introductions and as
we sat down were
i'm here to request that you reject
the electors in the disputed states and
you referenced a moment ago some
handwritten notes which you've provided
to the select committee i'd now like to
show you
those notes
uh as you can see you wrote there at the
top the writing's a little bit faint in
the copy but you wrote requesting vp
reject does that accurately reflect what
dr eastman asked of you
in your meeting on january 5th
yes
and what was your reaction when dr
eastman said on january 5th that he was
there to ask the vice president of the
united states to reject electors at the
joint session of congress
i was surprised because i had viewed it
as sort of one of the key concessions
that we had secured the night before
from mr eastman that
that he was not recommending that we do
that so what did you say to him
well as i
indicated
to some extent it simplified my task
because the
um
there are more procedural complexities
to the send it back to the state's point
of view and i actually had spent
most of my evening the night before
writing a memorandum to the vice
president explaining
um all of the specific provisions of the
electoral count act that plan would
violate
um so
instead
since he was
pushing
the
sort of robust unilateral power
theory
i've already walked the committee
through the discussions that we had we
again we
i started out with our points of
commonality uh or
buddy we're conservatives we're small
government people we believe in
originalism as the means that by which
we're going to interpret this and so we
walked through the text we walked
through the history
the committee has shown footage
of mr eastman on the stage on the sixth
claiming that jefferson supported his
position in a historical example of
jefferson in fact he conceded in that
meeting
jefferson did not at all support his
position that in the election of 1800
there had been some small technical
defect with the certificate in georgia
it was absolutely undisputed that
jefferson had won georgia jefferson did
not assert that he had any authority to
reject electors he did not assert that
he had any authority to resolve any
issue
um during the course of that
and so he acknowledged by the end
that there
was no historical practice whatsoever
that supported his position he had
initially tried to push
examples of jefferson and adams he
ultimately acknowledged they did not
work as we've covered he acknowledged it
would lose 9-0 in the supreme court he
again tried to say but i don't think the
courts will get involved in this
they'll invoke the political question
doctrine
and so
if the courts stay out of it
that will mean that we'll have the 10
days for the states to weigh in and
resolve it
um and then the
you know they'll send back the trump
slates of electors and the people will
be able to accept that and
i expressed my vociferous disagreement
with that point i did not think
that this was a political question
among other things if the courts
did not step in to resolve this
there was nobody else to resolve it
you would be in a situation where you
have a standoff between the president of
the united states and counterfactually
the vice president of the united states
saying that we've exercised authorities
that
constitutionally we think we have by
which we have deemed ourselves the
winners of the election
you would have an opposed house and
senate disagreeing with that
you would have state legislatures that
to that point i mean republican leaders
across those legislatures had put
together and put out statements and we
collected these for the vice president
as well
that the people had spoken in their
states and that they had no intention
of reversing the outcome of the election
we did receive some signed letters that
um mr eastman forwarded us by
minorities of leaders in those states
but
no state had any legislative house that
indicated that had any interest in it so
you would have had
just an unprecedented
constitutional junk ball situation with
that standoff and as i expressed to him
that issue might well then have to be
decided in the streets
because if we can't work it out
politically
we've already seen
how charged up people are about this
election
and so
it would be a disastrous situation to be
so i said i think the courts will
intervene i do not see
a commitment in the constitution of the
question whether the vice president has
that authority to some other actor to
resolve there there's arguments about
whether congress and the vice president
jointly
have a constitutional commitment to
generally decide electoral vote issues i
i don't think that they have any
authority to object
or reject them i don't see it in the
12th amendment but nonetheless
and i concluded by saying
john
in light of everything that we've
discussed
can't you we just both agree that this
is a terrible idea
um and he couldn't quite bring himself
to say yes to that but he very clearly
said
well
yeah i see we're not going to be able to
persuade you to do this and that was how
the meeting concluded
you just described a terrifying scenario
sounds like there could have been chaos
under the eastman approach and you even
described it as it potentially could be
decided in the streets
and you describe several concessions
that dr eastman made throughout that
discussion or even debate that you had
with him
at some point during that meeting on
january 5th
dr eastman seemed to
admit that both of the theories that he
had presented to the united states the
day before so
the theory that the vice president could
reject electors outright and declare
donald trump the winner
and his less aggressive theory
that
uh
the vice president could simply send it
back to the states at some point in that
conversation on the fifth did dr eastman
seem to admit that both of these
theories
suffered from similar legal flaws
so
i had
at least one possibly two other
conversations with dr eastman later that
day
in the earlier meeting we really were
focused because his request that he made
had been reject the electors outright
on why that theory was wrong and why we
certainly would not be doing
later that day
he pivoted back to
well
we hear you loud and clear you're not
going to reject
um but remember last night i said that
there was this more prudent course where
you could just send it back to the
states would you be willing to do that
and during the course of our discussion
about
his renewed request that we consider
that option
he
acknowledged to me
he put it
both mr eastman and myself are graduates
of the university of chicago law school
and he said look as
graduates of that august institution you
and i will
mutually understand that the underlying
legal theory
of plenary
vice presidential authority is what you
have to have to get there because
this new theory as i was pointing out to
him
or the procedural theory
still violates several provisions of the
electoral count act as he acknowledged
and the only way that you could ever be
able to ignore several provisions of
statutory law as if it was pretty clear
that they were unconstitutional
and the only way they could be
unconstitutional
is if the vice president had the plenary
authorities that were formed the basis
for the reject votes as well
so
he acknowledged in those conversations
that the underlying legal theory was the
same
he just thought that the send it back to
the states option
would be more politically palatable and
he hoped more palatable to the vice
president for that reason and in fact
when dr eastman made this concession
during that meeting according to your
earlier deposition
dr eastman said
just between us university of chicago
chickens is that right
i don't think that the university of
chicago is going to start a chicago
chicken's fundraiser
but yes that is the terminology that he
used he said you know just between us
chicago chickens we will understand
um as as lawyers who have studied the
constitution that the
underlying basis really is the same
i reserve the remainder of my time thank
you mr wood
mr jacob the president and the vice
president meet again on that same topic
the next day january 5th correct
there
so after my
extended meeting
with mr eastman that morning
during that time the vice president had
been back at his residence
working on his statement to the nation
that we released the next day
he
got down to the white house um
some point between one o'clock and two
o'clock as
my meeting
uh with mr eastman was wrapping up
and when we
mark short and i went over to meet with
the vice president
and
um actually we thought maybe we had good
news we felt like we had sort of
defeated uh mr eastman that he was sort
of acknowledging that there was no there
there
but the vice president was then um asked
down to the oval office
and he went down to the oval office
while mark and i stayed back in the vice
president's office you weren't in that
meeting
i was not
in the book peril journalist bob
woodward and robert costa write that the
president said quote
if these people say you have the power
wouldn't you want to
the vice president says quote i wouldn't
want any one person to have that
authority
the president responds but wouldn't it
almost be cool to have that power
vice president is reported to have said
no look i've read this and i don't see a
way to do it we've exhausted every
option i've done everything i could and
then some to find a way around this it's
simply not possible my interpretation is
no
to which the president says no no no
you don't understand mike you can do
this
i don't want to be your friend anymore
if you don't do this
we asked mark short about this during
his deposition
the understanding that i would have
um
in other conversations
with the vice president
he articulated to me
that
no he wouldn't want that power bestowed
upon any one person
mr jacob did you mr short and the vice
president have a call later that day
again with the president and dr eastman
so yes we did and what did dr eastman
request on that call
uh
on that phone call which
i believe was around five o'clock that
afternoon
um
mr
eastman stated that he had heard us loud
and clear that morning we were not going
to be rejecting electors
but
would we be open to considering the
other course that we had discussed on
the 4th which would be to
suspend the joint session
and request that state legislatures
re-examine
uh certification of the electoral votes
that same day january 5th the new york
times ran a story about the disagreement
between the president and the vice
president about whether the vice
president could determine the outcome of
the election
even though the new york times story was
indisputably correct
donald trump denied it
trump issued a statement claiming that
the vice president had agreed that he
could determine the outcome of the
election despite the fact that the vice
president had consistently rejected that
position
let's look at what the president said in
his statement
quote the new york times report
regarding comments vice president pence
supposedly made to me today is fake news
he never said that
the vice president and i are in total
agreement that the vice president has
the power to act
mr jacob how did the vice president's
team react to the statement from the
president that the vice president could
take an active role in determining the
winner of the presidential election
um so
uh
we were shocked and disappointed
because whoever had written and put that
statement out it was categorically
untrue
vice president's chief of staff mark
short had an angry phone call with trump
campaign senior adviser jason miller
about this statement
here's what mr short and mr miller told
the committee about that call
okay tell me about the conversation you
had with jason it was brief i
was um
irritated
and expressed uh displeasure that uh
statement could have gone out that
misrepresented the vice president's
viewpoint without consultation the
statement says the vice president and i
are in total agreement that the vice
president has the power to act is that
incorrect
i i think the record shows that that's
incorrect yeah i mean we've been through
many documents that clarify that this is
not where the vice president was right
so essentially
the president's sending out a boldly
false statement about being in alignment
purported alignment with the vice
president despite all of the predicate
that you indicated had gone before about
their respective positions is that
effectively what happened i interpret
this statement as false i'll let you
figure out who sent it out
when mark short contacted you
he was upset is that what she said
he clearly was not pleased
tell us what he said
what's the process for putting out a
statement
for a meeting where only two people were
in the room
did he ask you to retract the statement
no he just i think it went right to
what's the process for putting out a
statement
for a meeting when only two people were
in the room
and he clearly disagreed with the
substance though right because he said
that he said the vice president doesn't
agree with this
trying to think what exactly he said i
mean the the tone
i was very clearly
that uh
uh maybe he used some language to
uh strongly infer that the vice
president disagreed with with that take
but i don't remember what that language
was
did he dictate this statement
we
uh he dictated uh
he dictated most of it i mean typically
on these um
typically on these i might have a couple
of wording suggestions uh or
um maybe i
you know have a a sentence or a rough
framework or something of that
but i i know
with uh specifically on this one that it
was me and him on the phone talking
through it
and
ultimately the way this came out
was the way that he wanted to
the dispute between the president and
the vice president had grown to the
point where the vice president's chief
of staff mark short was concerned that
the president could in mr short's words
lash out at the vice president on
january 6th
in fact mr short was so concerned about
it that he talked with the head of the
vice president's secret service detail
on january 5th
here's mr short
concern was for the vice president's
security and so i wanted to make sure
the head of the vice president's secret
service was aware that
that likely
as these disagreements became more
public that the president would
lash out in some way
after the recess we will hear that mark
short's concerns were justified the vice
president was in danger
mr chairman i reserve
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
committee will be in order
a gentleman from california mr aguilar
is
recognized
i'd now like to turn to the events of
january 6 2021
which turned out to be a fateful day in
our nation's history
despite the fact that the vice president
consistently told the president that he
did not have and would not want the
power to decide the outcome of the
presidential election
donald trump continued to pressure the
vice president both publicly
and privately
as you will hear
things reached a boiling point on
january 6th
and the consequences were disastrous
in the middle of the night
on january 5th into the morning of the
6th around 1 am
president trump tweeted at
the vice president
meaning that the comments in response to
the president's tweet
would also show up on the vice
president's twitter feed
the tweet stated that
the vice president could
come through for us
and
send it back to the states
then around 8 am
on january 6th president trump again
tweeted
this time
to say that the vice president
could send it back to the states and
we win
and that this is the time
for extreme courage
told us during his deposition that the
vice president
started a meeting on january 6th
in prayer
here is what mr short said
you arrived at the vice president's
residence
as would often be the case i recall that
knowing it would be an important day
we gathered in prayer
and
often that would be something the staff
member would would lead so it would have
just been at that time i believe
the vice president myself
greg and chris
and
we would have just asked for
guidance and wisdom knowing that the day
was going to be a challenging one
mr jacob did you go to the vice
president's residences on the morning of
january 6th
yes
who else was with you
um mark short
devin o'malley our communications
director and chris hodgson our
legislative affairs director
did the vice president have a call with
the president that morning
he did
were you with the vice president during
the call
so we had been
um
putting the
the vice president had finalized his
statement overnight we were in the
process of proofing it so that we could
get that out
and
we were told that a call had come in
from the president
the vice president stepped out of the
room to take that call and no staff went
with him
the president had several family members
with him
in the oval
that morning for that call
i'd like to show you what they and
others told the select committee about
that call
along with never-before-seen photographs
of the president on that call from the
national archives
when i got in
uh
somebody called me and said that
the family and others were in the oval
and do i want to come up
so i i went upstairs uh and who do you
recall being in the oval office
uh don jr eric laura
kimberly i believe meadows was there
at some point ivanka
came in it wasn't a specific
formal discussion it was
very sort of loose and casual so then
you said at some point there's
a telephone conversation between the
president and the vice president is that
correct yes
when i entered the office the second
time
he was
on the telephone with who i later found
out to be was the the vice president
could you hear the vice president or
only hear the president's end i only
hear the president but at some point it
started off as a calmer tone and
everything and then became heated the
conversation was was
pretty heated
i think until it became
somewhat you know louder tone
i don't think anyone's paying attention
to it initially
did you hear any part of the phone call
even if just this the end that the
president was speaking from i did yes
all right and what'd you hear
so as i was dropping off the note um my
memory i remember hearing the word wimp
either he called him a wimp i don't
remember he said you are a wimp you'll
be a whim wimp is the word i remember
it's also been reported that the
president said to the vice president
that something to the effect of you
don't have the courage to make a hard
decision
i don't remember exactly either with
something like that yeah dude
like being you're not tough enough to
make the call it was a different tone
than i'd heard him take um with the vice
president before did miss trump share
with you any more details about what had
happened or any details about what had
happened in the oval office that morning
that her dad
had just had an upsetting conversation
with the vice president do you recall
anything about her demeanor either
during the meeting or when encountered
her in dance cabino's office
i don't remember specifically i mean i
think she was
uncomfortable over the fact that there
was obviously that type of interaction
between the two of them something to the
effect this is
the wording's wrong
i made the wrong decision four or five
years ago and the the word that she
related to that the president called the
vice president i apologize for being
impolite but do you remember what she
said her father called him
the p word
mr jacob how would you describe
the demeanor of the vice president
following the call following that call
with the president
when he came back into the room i'd say
that he was
steely
determined
graham
of course the most dangerous part of
what donald trump did on january 6th
was
what he did
himself
as we'll be discussed in detail in a
future hearing our investigation found
that early drafts of the january 6
ellipse speech prepared for the
president included no mention of the
vice president
but the president revised it to include
criticism of the vice president and then
further ad-libbed
here is what the president said on
january 6th after his call with vice
president pence
i hope mike is going to do the right
thing i hope so
i hope so
because if mike pence does the right
thing
we win the election all vice president
pence has to do is send it back to the
states to recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
[Applause]
and i actually
i just spoke to mike i said mike that
doesn't take courage what takes courage
is to do nothing
that takes courage and then we're stuck
with a president who lost the election
by a lot and we have to live with that
for four more years we're just not going
to let that happen and mike pence is
going to have to come through for us and
if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
and
they want to re-certify their votes
they want to re-certify but the only way
that can happen is if mike pence agrees
to send it back
so i hope mike has the courage to do
what he has to do
and i hope he doesn't listen to the
rhinos and the stupid people that he's
listening to
of course we all know what happened next
the president's words had an effect
president trump's supporters became
angry
when the vice president issued his
public letter the crowd at the capitol
erupted in anger
the rioters who had erected makeshift
gallows began chanting hang mike pence
testimony in our investigation has made
clear
what the target of the rioters ire was
vice president mike pence
the rioters breached the capitol
at 2 13 pm
now let's take a look at what was going
on at the white house at this time
we received testimony that the
president's chief of staff mark meadows
was notified of the violence at the
capitol
by 2 pm and likely earlier
the testimony further establishes that
mr meadows quickly informed the
president and that he did so before
the president issued his 2 24 pm tweet
criticizing vice president pence for not
having quote
courage to do what needed to be done
here is what the president wrote in his
2 24 pm tweet
while the violence at the capitol was
going on
and here is what the rioters thought
nothing but a traitor and he deserves to
burn with the rest of them so this is
all escalated after pence what what
happened to pence
pence didn't do what we wanted pence
voted against trump okay and that's when
all this started yep that's when we
marched on the capitol we've been shot
at with rubber bullets tear death
we've just heard
[Applause]
has betrayed the united states of
america
my friend has betrayed this president
and he has betrayed the people of the
united states and we will never ever
forget yeah
[Applause]
it's real simple
hence betrayed us
which apparently everybody knew he was
going to
and the president mentioned it
like five times when he talked
you can go back and watch the
president's video
this is our capital let's be respectful
to him
there's four million people coming in
[Applause]
it's only a matter of time justice is
coming
although the president's chief of staff
mark meadows has refused to testify
before this committee mr meadows aide
ben williamson and white house deputy
press secretary sarah matthews testified
that mr meadows went to the dining room
near the oval office to tell the
president about the violence at the
capitol before
the president's 2 24 pm tweet
in future hearings you'll hear more
about exactly what was happening in the
white house at that time
but here is what some white house staff
told the select committee
do you know where he went
uh yes i followed him down the hallway
and i followed him
into the outer oval corridor
which is the hallway between
the oval office
hallway
and the outer oval section of the oval
office
i followed him into that little corridor
hallway
i saw him walk into outer oval
i maybe took a step into outer oval and
then left uh and i don't know where he
went outside of that but it looked like
he was headed in the direction of the
oval office
you know we had all
talked about at that point about how it
was um bad and the um you know situation
was getting out of hand
and um
i know ben williamson and i were uh
conferring and
we thought that the president needed to
tweet something and tweet something
immediately
and i think when kaylee gave us that
order of don't say anything to the media
i
told her that i thought the president
needed to tweet something
and
um
then
i remember um
then i remember getting um a
notification on my phone and i was
sitting in a room with
roma and ben
and
we all got a notification
so
we knew it was a tweet from the
president
and we looked down
and it was
a tweet about mike pence uh i believe i
had sent him a text
uh saying that we may want to put out
some sort of statement
uh because the situation was
was getting a little hairy over at the
capitol
and it was common for after i would text
him
uh i would just go down and
see him in person you went down to speak
with mark meadows after this what was
that conversation
uh very brief i went down and told him
the same thing i have in the text that i
can recall
um
and i i don't remember anything that was
said uh between us other than i told him
that
uh and to my recollection he immediately
got up and uh and left his office
our investigation found that immediately
after the president's 2 24 pm tweet the
crowds both outside the capitol and
inside the capitol surged
the crowds inside the capitol were able
to overwhelm the law enforcement
presence and the vice president was
quickly evacuated from his ceremonial
senate office to a secure location
within the capitol complex
by 2 24 pm the secret service had moved
vice president pence from the senate
chamber to his office across the hall
the noise from the riders became audible
at which point we recognized that maybe
they had gotten into the building then
president trump tweeted
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
giving states a chance to certify a
corrected set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify
usa demands the truth
it was clear that it was escalating and
escalating quickly
[Music]
so then when
that tweet the mike pence tweet
um was sent out um i remember us saying
that that was the last thing that needed
to be tweeted at that moment
the situation was already bad and so it
felt like he was pouring gasoline on the
fire by tweeting that
30 seconds later rioters already inside
the capitol
opened the east rotunda door
just down the hall
and just 30 seconds after that
rioters breached the crypt
one floor below the vice president the
secret service couldn't control the
situation and do their job of keeping
him safe at 2 26 pm
secret service rushed vice president
pence down the stairs i think they've
been trying to figure out whether they
had a clear route
to get us to wherever it was that they
wanted to move this too we moved pretty
quickly downstairs and through various
hallways and tunnels to the secure
location upon arriving there there was
further discussion as to whether or not
we were going to leave the capitol
complex or stay where we were
vice president pence and his team
ultimately were led to a secure location
where they stayed for the next four and
a half hours
barely missing rioters a few feet away
approximately 40 feet
that's all there was
40 feet between the vice president and
the mob
mr jacob you were there
sing that for the first time
does it surprise you to see how close
the mob was to the evacuation route that
you took
the 40 feet is the distance from me to
you roughly
i could hear the den of the rioters in
the building while we moved but i don't
think i was aware that they were as
close as that
make no mistake about the fact that the
vice president's life was in danger
a recent court filing by the department
of justice explains that a confidential
informant from the proud boys told the
fbi the proud boys would have killed
mike pence if given a chance
this witness
whom the fbi affidavit refers to as w1
stated that other members of the group
talked about things they did that day
and they said that anyone they got their
hands on they would have killed
including nancy pelosi
w1 further stated that members of the
proud boys said
that they would have killed mike pence
if given a chance
we understand that congressional leaders
and others were evacuated from the
capitol complex during the attack
we'd like to show you what happened
after the vice president was evacuated
from the senate
select committee has obtained
never-before-seen photos from the
national archives that show vice
president pence sheltering in a secure
underground location as rioters
overwhelmed the capital
at 4 19 pm
vice president pence is seen looking at
a tweet the president had just sent
a tweet asking the rioters to capital
after four and a half hours
spent on working to restore order
the vice president returned to the
senate floor to continue the
certification of
so vice president pence was a focus of
the violent attack
mr jacob did the vice president leave
the capitol complex during the attack
he did not
can you please explain why the vice
president refused to leave the capitol
complex
when we got down to the secure location
secret service directed us to get into
the cars
which i did
and then i noticed that the vice
president had not so i got out of the
car that i had gotten and gotten into
and i understood that the vice president
had refused to get into the car
the
head of his secret service detail tim
had said
i assure you we're not going to drive
out of the building without your
permission and the vice president had
said something to the effect of
tim i know you i trust you but you're
not the one behind the wheel and the
vice president did not want to take
any chance
that
um the world would see the vice
president of the united states fleeing
the united states capital he was
determined that we would complete the
work that we had um set out to do that
day that it was his constitutional duty
to see through
and the the
rioters who had breached the capital
would not have the satisfaction of
disrupting
the proceedings beyond the day on which
they were supposed to be completed
let me see if i understand this right
you were told to get in the cars
and how many of the vice president's
staff got into cars while he did not
most of us
during our investigation we received
testimony that while the vice president
was in a secure location within the
capital complex he continued the
business of government
we understand that the vice president
reached out to congressional leaders
like the acting secretary of defense and
others to check on their safety and to
address the growing crisis
in addition the vice president's chief
of staff mark short made several calls
to senior government officials
here's mr short's testimony regarding
his call with representative kevin
mccarthy
he indicated that uh
he had had some conversation i don't
recall whether it was with the president
or somebody at the white house but i
think he he expressed uh frustration
that uh um not taking the circumstance
as seriously as they showed that moment
so mr mccarthy indicated he'd been in
touch with someone at the white house
and he conveyed to you that they weren't
taking this as seriously as they should
while the vice president made several
calls to check on the safety of others
it was his own life that was in great
danger
mr jacob did donald trump ever call the
vice president to check on his safety
he did not
mr jacob how did vice president pence
and mrs pence react to that
with frustration
mr jacob immediately before you and the
vice president were evacuated to a
secure location within the capitol
you hit send on an email to john eastman
explaining why his legal theory
about the vice president's role was
wrong
you ended your email
by stating that quote
thanks to your [ __ ] we are now under
siege
we'll take a look at that email
dr eastman
replied
and this is hard to believe but his
reply back to you was
the siege
is because you
and your boss presumably referring to
the vice president in the united states
did not do what was necessary to allow
this to be aired in a public way so the
american people can see for themselves
what happened
mr jacob later that day you wrote again
to dr eastman let's show that email on
the screen
in that email you wrote and i quote did
you advise the president that in your
professional judgment the vice president
does not have the power to decide things
unilaterally
and you ended that email saying it does
not appear that the president ever got
the memo
dr eastman then replied
he's been so advised
and he ends his email with
quote but you know him
once he gets something in his head
it's hard to get in a change course
close quote
mr jacob when dr eastman wrote once he
gets something in his head it's hard to
get him to change course did you
understand the he in that email
to refer to the president of the united
states
i did
and mr jacob did you hear from dr
eastman further
after the riot had been quelled and if
so
what did he ask
late that evening
after the joint session had been
reconvened
the vice president had given
a statement to the nation saying that
violence was not going to win freedom
wins
and that the people were going to get
back to doing their work
later that evening
mr eastman emailed me
to point out that in his view the vice
president's speech
to the nation
um violated the electoral count act that
the electoral count act had been
violated because the debate on arizona
had not been completed in two hours
um of course it couldn't be since there
was an intervening riot of several hours
and the speeches that the majority of
minority leaders had been allowed to
make also violated the electoral count
act because they hadn't been counted
against the debate time
and then he implored me
now that we have established that the
electoral count act um isn't so
sacrosanct as
you have made it out to be
i implore you one last time can the vice
president please do what we've been
asking him to do these last two days
suspend the joint session send it back
to the states
and we'll show you the text of that
email which dr eastman wrote at 11 44
p.m
on january 6th so after the attack on
the capital and after law enforcement
had secured the capital
he still wrote as you described quote so
now that the precedent has been set that
the electoral count act is not quite so
sacrosanct as was previously claimed
i implore you to consider
one more relatively minor violation and
adjourn for 10 days to allow the
legislatures to finish their
investigations so even after the attack
on the capital of benquel dr eastman
requested
in writing no less
that the vice president violate the law
by delaying the certification and
sending the question back to the states
is that correct mr jacob
it is
did you eventually share dr eastman's
proposal with vice president pence
not right at that time because the vice
president was completing uh the work um
that it was his duty to do
but a day or two later back at the white
house i did show him the um that final
email from mr eastman and what was vice
president pence's reaction when you
showed him the email where dr eastman
after the attack on the capitol still
asked that the vice president delay
certification and send it back to the
states
he said
that's rubber room stuff
i'm i'm sorry
he said it's rubber room stuff
yes congressman what did you interpret
that to mean
i understood it to mean that
after having seen play out
um
what happens when you
convince people that there is a decision
to be made in the capital legitimately
about who is to be the president and the
consequences of that he was still
pushing us to do
what
he had been asking us to do for the
previous two days
that that was
certifiably crazy
we know that the vice president did not
do what dr eastman requested because he
presided over the completion of the
counting of electoral votes late in that
evening
number of electors appointed to vote for
president of the united states is 538.
within that whole number a majority is
270.
the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
the whole number of electors appointed
to vote for vice president of the united
states is 538
that whole number a majority is 270.
the votes for vice president of the
united states are as follows
kamala d harris of the state of
california
has received 306 votes
michael r pence of the state of indiana
has received 232 votes
the announcement of the state of the
vote
by the president of the senate
shall be deemed a sufficient declaration
of the persons elected president and
vice president of the united states each
for the term beginning on the 20th day
of january
2021 and shall be entered together with
the list of the votes on the journals of
the senate and the house of
representatives
mr jacob we heard earlier that you and
the vice president and the team started
january 6 with a prayer
you faced a lot of danger that day
and this is a personal question
but how did your faith guide you on
january 6th
um
my faith really sustained me through it
um
i
down in the secure location um
pulled out my bible um read through it
um and
i just
took great comfort um
daniel 6 uh was where i went and um
in daniel 6
daniel has become the
second in command of babylon a pagan
nation but he
completely faithfully serves
he refuses an order from the king
that he cannot follow
and he does his duty
inc consistent with his oath to god and
i felt that that's what had played out
that day
it spoke to you
yes
at the end of the day mark short sent
the vice president a text message with
the bible verse here's what he told the
select committee
at
3 50 in the morning when we finally
adjourned and
headed our own ways
i remember
texting the vice president a a passage
from second timothy chapter four seven
about um i fought the good fight i
finished the race i've kept the faith
he started his day with the prayer
and ended his day with a bible verse
i've
fought the good fight i finished the
race i've kept the faith
white house attorney
eric hirschman testified that the next
day january 7th
he received a call from dr eastman
here is mr hershman's account of that
call
the day after
uh
eastman
i don't remember why he called me and he
or he texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
ask me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
all right i said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
now the screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
and actually
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're gonna need it
and then i hung up on them
in fact just a few days later dr eastman
emailed rudy giuliani and requested that
he be included on a list of potential
recipients of a presidential pardon
dr eastman's email stated quote
i've decided that i should be on the
pardon list if that is still in the
works
dr eastman did not receive his
presidential pardon
so let's see what dr eastman did
as a result when he was deposed by this
committee
i assert my fifth amendment right
against being compelled to be a witness
against myself
did the trump legal team ask you to
prepare a memorandum regarding the vice
president's role in the accounting of
electoral votes at the joint session of
congress on january 6 2022.
dr eastman did you advise the president
of the united states that the vice
president could reject electors from
seven states and declare that the
president had been realized
dr eastman the first sentence of the
memo
starts off by saying seven states have
transmitted dual slates of electors to
the president of the senate
is that statement in this memo true
fifth
did president trump authorize you to
discuss publicly or january 4th
2021 conversation with them
uh
so is it your position that you can
discuss in the media direct
conversations you had with the president
of the united states but you will not
discuss those same conversations with
this committee
dr eastman plead to fifth
a hundred times
finally let's hear from a federal court
judge the only one to date who is opined
on whether the president was involved in
criminal activity
page 36 of judge carter's ruling says
quote based on the evidence the court
finds it more likely than not that the
president president trump
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
page 40 of the ruling says
quote based on the evidence the court
finds that it is more likely than not
that president trump and dr eastman
dishonestly conspired to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
in page 44
dr eastman and president trump launched
a campaign to overturn a democratic
election in action unprecedented in
american history
their campaign was not confined to the
ivory tower
it was a coup in search of a legal
theory
mr jacob what would have happened to our
democracy if vice president pence had
gone along with this plan and certified
donald trump as the winner of the 2020
election
so there would have been
short-term and long-term effects
the short term i've previously described
a constitutional jump ball situation
political chaos in washington
lawsuits
and who knows what's happening in the
streets and you would have had the vice
president of the united states having
declared
um that the outcomes of these state
elections were incorrect um so for all
of those reasons
there would have been significant
short-term consequences
but in the long term
um
we would have established a situation
where a vice president
would have asserted
that one person could have the authority
to determine the outcome of an election
which is antithetical to everything in
our democracy
it's antithetical to the rule of law
and so
it would have been um
significant impacts both in the short
and the long term
judge ludwig in the statement you
released earlier today you wrote that
the efforts by president trump to
overturn the 2020 election were quote
the most reckless insidious and
calamitous failures in both legal and
political judgment in american history
what did you mean by that
exactly what i said congressman
thank you judge
thank you mr jacob mr chairman i yield
back
gentlemen i'm
i'm sorry mr chairman i want that back
mr chairman this was an informative
hearing a powerful hearing
i'm grateful for your leadership and the
leadership of the distinguished vice
chair
donald trump knew he lost the 2020
election
but he could not bring himself to
participate in the peaceful transfer of
power
so he latched on to a scheme that once
again
he knew was illegal
and when the vice president refused to
go along with it he unleashed a violent
mob against him
when we began i asked how we got to this
place
and i think the answer to that question
starts with the fact that people in
positions of power
put their political party before their
country
they cannot be allowed to continue
i'll yield back now mr chairman
thank you very much without objection
the chair recognizes the gentlewoman
from wyoming ms cheney for a closing
statement
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you to my colleague representative
aguilar and thank you very much to our
witnesses today mr jacob and judge
ludwig thank you for for being here with
us
um we have seen so far in in our
hearings that president trump knew that
his claims of a stolen election were
false
you have seen that i knew that mike
pence could not legally refuse to count
electoral votes
and you have seen what might what
president trump did to pressure mike
pence into taking illegal action
over the course of our next hearings you
will see information about president
trump's efforts
john eastman efforts the trump legal
team's efforts to apply pressure to
republican state legislatures state
officials and others
judge carter has recently written quote
dr eastman's actions in these few weeks
indicate that his and president trump's
pressure campaign to stop the electoral
count did not end with vice president
pence it targeted every tier of federal
and state elected officials
we will examine all of those threats
and we will examine the trump team's
determination to transmit materially
false electoral slates from multiple
states to officials of the executive and
legislative branches of our government
we will examine the pressures put on
state legislatures to convene to reverse
lawful election results
an honorable man
receiving the information and advice
that mr trump received from his campaign
experts and his staff
a man who loved his country
more than himself
would have conceded this election
indeed we know that a number of
president trump's closest aides urged
him to do so
this committee will address all of these
issues in greater detail in the coming
weeks mr chairman i yield back
young lady yields back
judge eluded
and mr jacob
our nation owes your great debt
for your knowledge integrity
and your loyalty to our constitution
you and vice president pence
are exactly the people our nation needed
at a critical time
you had the courage to do what was right
in the weeks leading up to january 6th
many people failed this test when they
had to choose between their oath to the
country
or the demands of donald trump
but there were others who like you stood
tall
in the face of intimidation
and put our democracy first
they include the judges who rejected the
bogus claims of election fraud
the senior justice department officials
who stood up to donald trump
and the state officials whom we will
hear from at our next hearing
we are deeply grateful to your courage
and devotion to our country
there are some who think the danger has
passed
that even though there were violence and
a corrupt attempt to overturn the
presidential election
the system worked
i look at it another way
our system nearly failed and our
democratic foundation destroyed
but for people like you
judge ludic
i want to give you an opportunity to
share your thoughts
on the ongoing threat
you've written the clear and present
danger to our democracy
now is that former president donald
trump and other political allies
appear prepared
to seize the presidency in 2024 if mr
trump
are one of his anointed candidates
is not elected by the american people
what do you mean by this
mr chairman
i'm honored beyond words
by your words
i was honored on january 6
2021
then
also honored beyond words
to have been able
to come to the aid
of vice president
mike
pence
i prayed that day
just like
the vice president prayed that day
i believe we may have prayed
the same prayer to the same god
i prayed
that same prayer
with my wife this morning before i came
into these hearings
i have written
as you said
chairman thompson
that
today
almost two years after
that fateful day
in january 2021
that's still
donald trump
and his
allies and supporters
are a clear and present danger
to american democracy
that's not because
of what happened on january 6th
it's because to this very day
the former president
his allies and supporters
pledge
that in
the presidential
election of 2024
if
the former president
or
his anointed
successor as the republican party
presidential candidate
were to
lose
that election
that they would
attempt to overturn that 2024 election
in the same way that they
attempted to overturn
the 2020 election
but succeed
in 2024 where they failed
in 2020.
i don't speak those words
lightly
i would have never
spoken
those words ever in my life
except that
that's what
the former president and his allies
are telling us
as i said in that new york times op-ed
wherein i was speaking
about the electoral count act of 1887
the former president and his allies
are
executing that blueprint
for 2024
in
open
and plain view
of the american public
i repeat
i would have never uttered one single
one of those words
unless the former president and his
allies
were
candidly
and proudly
speaking those
exact words
to america
chairman
thank you for the opportunity to appear
here today for these
proceedings thank you again uh
judge looted
as a part of the select committee's
charge to make recommendations
that are informed by other investigative
findings
we will be reviewing the views shared by
judge looted and other experts on
potential improvements to electoral
account act among a range of other
initiatives
i know the information we presented over
the last week
is shocking
the idea that a president of the united
states
would orchestrate a kink a scheme
to stay in power after the people have
voted him out of office
we're able to present this information
because so many witnesses have
cooperated with our probe
but the fact is there are more people
with direct knowledge
with evidence
germane to our investigation
i ask those who might be on the fence
about cooperating to reach out to us
the committee's website address is being
displayed behind me
january 6th.house.gov
there you can view the evidence we
presented in our hearings and find a tip
line to submit any information you might
think would be helpful for our
investigation
and
despite how you might not think it's
important
send us what you think
and i thank those who sent us evidence
for their bravery and patriotism
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record including
opening remarks and additional questions
for the witnesses
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated until the capitol
police have escorted members from the
room without objection the committed
stands are joined
you